Okay, so there is a total blizzard right now.
Look how much snow there is.
I have no power right now.
No power right now.
But thank god I got this freaking thing from the TikTok shop.
It's solar powered,
so I can just set this thing in the window
and keep my phone charged and keep doing things.
So I'm just gonna stay snuggled with my dog.
Oh, and we can enjoy the fucking weather.
Kind of whatever this thing is.
I'm so glad I got this.
This isn't just for the zombie apocalypse and for fucking peppers.
This is for, like,
real life shit,
like a normal fucking spring blizzard.
It's, like, right here.
If you want one from the TikTok shop,
I highly recommend it.